hey hey it's July 4th what you know
what's the hell am I doing here what are
we doing here I can't believe we're at
work that's actually had a little
barbecue in the corner here I got alipin
hotdogs we should really do July 4th
here in the studio and really do it the
way we're supposed maybe I would do it
no it's a perfect room no windows no
sunlight right that could be hid that
can do all the things I want to do in
life and nobody can see yeah welcome to
the podcast everyone faithful hope you
guys enjoyed Monday's episode Wednesday
July 4th hope you guys are enjoying your
time happy birthday America yes we are
doing a special mailbag fentruck has
notes all over the place hundreds of
responses and they got weird huh super
weird like so weird so weird that we
might not be able to use some of them my
porn habits that was that was
interesting we're not gonna get there
today because we don't want to give Josh
the mother hand too many stressors
heading into this holiday week but well
done by you organizing this thank you
you look really handsome in the off
season - whoa I'm gonna cut the sleeves
off this tonight to be my new podcast
t-shirt ok let's do some curls or so
practically involve big Phil yeah we're
getting Phil in ten minutes and he's
gonna be part of this we're just gonna
ask him questions you wanna explain how
this is gonna go okay so in front of you
guys pal yeah you have two sheets of
paper in front of you that has the eight
categories that the questions have been
organized into we've got real football
questions ridiculous football questions
personal questions legs and ass pot
questions very popular topic this time
yeah self Scouting animals and big Phil
so those are eight categories and the
ways is gonna go we're gonna start with
left go he's gonna tell me what category
he wants a question from we'll go down
the list we'll do it you pick the next
category you're amazing back in fine I
don't even know about this suggestion
it'sit's the fact that you have nine
other jobs don't all right we're gonna
utilize the Google Doc deflecting you
put them in the Google Doc higher-ups
might be listening I'm just going to fly
every time Google does it for you okay
so I think we get started here right I
want to start with a personal question
personal question okay let's dig in deep
Simms I really are what your real name
here we go so the first personal
question here at deep honed 44 this was
on Instagram yeah Aaron Rodgers and
Odell Beckham are coming in to be our
for a podcast if all three of you
complete one of four tasks no repeats
which task do you each pick number one
full-body wax excluding head all right
so that's definitely Josh cuz the end of
the question is important here okay
Hendrix Sims left go is the order so I
get to go first you pick laughs oh so
number one oh you [ __ ]
full body wax number two one
three-minute UFC round versus Tony
Boselli number three no wieder alcohol
for one year and number four grow a
moustache for the entire NFL season so
that's full body wax Wow Tony Boselli
UFC no tweeter alcohol for a year
mustache for the entire NFL season so
what are you going you have first okay
I'm gonna go grow a mustache for the
entire NFL season number one I don't
really grow facial hair all that well so
by the end of the season it might
actually look good and number two I've
been looking for an excuse to grow a
mustache so getting Odell Beckham around
routers on the podcast I would gladly
grow a mustache he's screwed here so
Sims you're up next full body wax Tony
Boselli
or Weiner alcohol none of it for a year
well I mean there's no way I'm picking
no weed for a year so I could tell you
off the books you lost me there
so the okay so that becomes between weed
and this I mean wax and viselli okay I
mean hey listen we got to be in the air
man the Superboy I don't like hair as is
so I will wax myself no problem I don't
have a lot of hair I don't have a lot of
hair I mean I would rather not wax my
whole body but I will do it for the sake
of not cos this is coming down to how
much of a degenerate I am or do I fight
for my life a year of alcohol
I'll bite him and the good news is
Rogers and Odell Beckham are coming on
the podcast that's awesome I like that
that was a good to pick a category
you're up next
okay all right well I mean this we were
to a personal let's go with the pot
question let's just go there let's go
there were a lot of these first of all
so I'll just get this one out of the way
at de Moo's Harrison did Sims end up
blowing down with Ice Cube the answer
that is no no next question here at rod
Simba indica sativa and if you could
name your own strain what would it be
called this was a I believe this was a
conversation with Florio correct and you
had to explain that to what this was to
Mike Florio
I must achieve a guy all the way they
call me Chris sativa Sims on the pro
football talk now apparently yes I must
achieve a guy in what does that mean
Chris well VIP sativas of course there
are more of your social daytime highs
right or just you want to go out and be
able to conversate in because the one
that's gonna put you on the couch and
your billing Oh
where's the next bag of chips every now
and then I do if I know like I'm like
seriously not gonna get off the couch
and I'm like you know I'm sure dad was
here for this we could actually get him
in these he that would actually be funny
to hear him assess me as he watches me
smoke weed like a tape right down to
name your own shrimp oh the blond bomber
no see I think you're should be spleen
buster sometimes you get a strand it's
like it's either really aggressive or
kind of cute I think you should go
smoothly buster
yeah mine would be the left coaster ride
the left coaster that's a good one I
would probably be survivor boy alright
let's go pick your next category here
let's go let's go you know what self
scouting let the fans tell us where we
are wrong so we got we got some really
good awesome so some really good self
scouting questions so this one here I
guess we're too hard on the Falcons no
none of that
so DJ both 32 hey left go I've been
listening to a long to the podcast a
long time and really love your show
I do have a question however on some
self scouting when you guys talk about
players not knowing about other players
when voting on the top 100 how can you
expect players to vote on other players
into the Hall of Fame instead of the
writers keeping my fingers crossed for a
golden ticket to the draft party very
good question I'll enter it first okay
I'll just throw this this is the thing
Hall so when I say players to vote for
the Hall of Fame I don't want the
players that are playing now of course
some of them they never even saw Brian
Dawkins play or some of those guys so
they're not gonna be only know so my big
thing is the players I would love to see
players and the X Hall of Famers there's
some sort of form of committee of people
that we could just know who could be
that we know have really followed the
sport is basically what I'm saying the
top 100 again it's basically you come
into the locker room and maybe 10 15
guys are handed a sheet and they're like
write down your top 20 players and some
guys like going into a meeting he's a
cold let me finish my top 20 he writes
it down and the other issue with that is
there yes like like I've said here
before you know guys in the locker room
in the NFL like I said you know there's
a good percentage of guys that go home
and they don't really pay attention to
anything football they just show up the
next day and they're ready to do their
job of football we're okay if that's 53
guys on a team I'm gonna say like 15 to
20 or like that and then the other 30
are paying attention to football
certainly but there's like out of those
other 30 let's just say 20 are just on a
topical level like I turned on the
Monday Night Football game I didn't
watch every play but I basically saw the
major points and then you have your 10
or 15 guys on a team they're like they
know everything that's going on in the
league they're reading everything
they've watched everything so I guess
that's long story short yes it's hard
but yeah you'd have to find that right
group of I think X coaches and
ex-players ago know these are the Qualla
phil simms of the world the Dan Fouts of
the world guys that maybe not you know
Dan Fouts is in the Hall of Fame but
those are the rich Gannon you've been
paying attention to football you know
for a long time actually I think it
should be an assorted committee yeah
like there are some media members that
are very exactly the are Peter Kings
should be on it until he passes away all
right let's be real
so think that NFL players should be
involved I think there should be a test
I think that you should ask these guys
history questions from your knowledge
yeah like who's currently in the Hall of
Fame and there's like a list of ten
because if you don't know that a guy's
in the Hall of Fame then I don't think
you should be voting on the Hall of Fame
I think that when you vote there should
be so much preparation that I think you
need to come in there with knowledge
this is the Hall of Fame
we are immortalizing people forever top
100 it's a it's a marketing ploy from
the NFL Network to get you to watch when
the seasons not going on Hall of Fame I
need testing I need I need logistics I
and I want media and players combine
really just let Sims and love go do the
deciding vote whatever do it here DJ bow
thanks for the question good question
though Nick let's get big Phil on the
phone real football okay let's see here
all right here we go
glow money glow bands on Instagram if
you could bring back one player into the
NFL currently who would it be
someone like mike vick with a kyle or an
ik they a physical freak like bo Jackson
Deion Sanders in the social media era
one player bring back to the NFL it's
one of those names right there it's Bo
Jackson for me one second we're having a
real conversation actually Phil we're
gonna ask you the question ask him after
this my mind just think of some all-time
great set but mine would be Bo Jackson
because I don't think we ever got to see
the real full potential of Oh Jackson
just think about this for two seconds
first of all the guy went from being
like one of the best players and
baseball and then didn't do training
camp or anything and then would come to
the NFL and be one of the best running
backs in football within like the third
week of him playing so we never even got
to see bo Jackson at his best and I
would argue that he goes in the
conversation from one of the greatest
athletes in the history of the planet he
would be a guy that I would say there's
asked the question because if I had to
pick one NFL play every big fella yeah
before you give your answer big fill
it's your arch nemesis Josh here looking
forward to our ping-pong match coming up
sometime this summer
so it's the mailbag episode of the
podcast here taking questions from the
fans and glo money glow bands on
Instagram wants to know if you could
bring back one player into the NFL
currently who would it be in the example
he gave was someone like Michael Vick
with a Kyle Shanahan or Sean McVeigh
left go you're all coming to you next
I'm gonna go big phil simms I would love
to see Phil Simms in today's NFL with
five-yard cushions and a coach that
doesn't treat him like [ __ ] yeah I
definitely would like to throw some of
those screen passes that's for sure you
know thought bubble pass boys accurately
up the church while I love him okay so
that's good good do you want me yeah how
do you think he was like a guy from the
past you'd go see Anthony to see there's
so many you know you did Bo Jackson
thing listen the Bo Jackson 34:30
he was one of the best I've ever seen
and you know I heard all about his
college exploits him playing in baseball
and I go that's all bull they're just
building it up to make his price in NFL
better and then when I saw the 30 for 30
I went and of course I could see him in
the pros I went oh my gosh he was if he
could have separated both he would be in
a Baseball Hall of Fame and the Pro
Football Hall of Fame
yeah if he could have you know that wear
and tear if you notice his last year I
thought in football when he got hurt he
was losing speed you know the body this
never had time to recover right but who
would I you know I got one the first one
that comes off the top of my head
is Terry Bradshaw hmm
you know what would Terry Bradshaw do in
today's the game where you could move a
little throw the ball what we know now
and you know we we have to change that
throwing motion you know you got to
change it you know why because I read a
thing once he says I just go to training
camp every year and I just kept fooling
with the football and this and that
and figure out a way to grip it
just figure out a different way to throw
it and just that was this thing that's a
while but I'd get it right hand but
because size speed strength all those
things man I mean he would yeah
I can't even compare him to anybody that
comes up to draft that we got all go
crazy you know I guess you'd say michael
vick except he's just bigger and
stronger than michael vick the three
names that just came to my mind i would
love to see how jim brown did in this
era i would love to see what Barry
Sanders would do in any era yeah that's
what would be randall cunningham with
some freaking coaching i would love to
know what randall could imagine point I
think Randall Cunningham just was
unfortunately ahead of his time yes and
what else he's done a kind of head coach
that was all about defense and after I
am that's right let's just cut practice
short session up offense we all need to
come on I've told some of them those
stories I know it's it's unbelievable
you want to get filled choose a category
Oh fill questions so we had some of the
listeners submitted questions
specifically for you so we're gonna go
with one from Hayden Hall eight on
Instagram if you want a DMM Phil Hayden
Hall eight I've been a Giants fan my
whole life but I was born in 1996 so I
never got to see the greatest
quarterback in Giants history whose game
most resembles his in the current NFL
ooh which game what who's who's plyers
game you think is like in the NFL right
now you think is closest to your game oh
boy that's hard to come up with I know
yeah I probably need your expertise or
Adams to do it
Carson Wentz oh god no I couldn't run
like Carson went okay you're both small
school guys that were taken out of
nowhere that went in the first round
you could run pretty damn good early on
in your career well you know listen if
you put me in today's world if I grew up
knowing what these kids get to go
through growing up now then a
course I would have been a different
player yeah but I would say in today's
world I think you have Phillip Rivers
attitude playing football to degree I
like that I like that yeah I mean you
know I think I hated more than he did
you know I just it wasn't it wasn't it
was amazing
I just loved winning certain against
certain teams and I've told y'all this
walk across the field take the other
quarterbacks hand and it took everything
I had did not go hide like that but I
take Kirk Cousins okay you know and you
know I say that nerd and and like a lot
just because your cousin's physically
it's just so much better then everybody
gives him credit for ya know there you
go yeah okay I can see that a lot I
think you throw he throws it better than
Kirk Cousins does though I'll say that
maybe cuz again here's the other thing
like I told you guys right I didn't know
what you think about throwing and
Christopher and my son Matt I've told
you this Adam and John hey they used to
sit and watch the tapes of me and laugh
they go look I mean just because it was
so not structured you know I backpedal I
would run one way run another whatever
we want nobody cared just complete the
pass it's all that mattered so and and
my son knows this more than anybody
knowing what I do about throwing now and
I've said this many times when I was 55
for about 15 or 20 throws I told y'all
this I could throw it harder than I
could in my prime right because I knew
how to write now you know after 15
throws you don't go home and get a drink
get rid of pain but that's that's that's
something else so you know that's times
change and man these players coming out
now I'm just jealous of hell I'm jealous
about everything one more question from
the big fill category here at Jake GP 13
when did big fill no Chris was going to
be a good quarterback
at what point in Chris's career did you
know you had an NFL caliber son you want
me just
give you the real truth or the real
truth the real truth oh geez
I don't know when he was four maybe five
that Yabut latest but I knew it for I
knew when he was three four years old I
just went oh man you know I got brothers
and sisters and all that stuff and I've
been around I said he could hit a
baseball he could throw it he could run
and he he I looked at him you know cuz I
learned this from my father he and
Christopher you guys laugh about all the
time I know damn he's got big hands got
long legs yeah hell is my dad said as I
told you as he met my wife oh how you
doing and that was about the end of the
conversation he walked away he goes
she's gonna raise you some big strong
boys
[Laughter]
but you know honestly I swear to you I
really thought he would be a
professional athlete when he was four or
five years old last question here and
then we'll go back to the normal
categories at view me cases Chris Sims
versus old [ __ ] and armwrestling
current-day who wins Oh before you guys
answer let's go do you want to give your
your opinion on this one all right so
Phil has a lot of arm depth you know
it's like he's got a thick shoulder he's
got a thick elbow yes I also just looked
at my elbow yeah I did I'm also thinking
then Phil there's there's two things
factoring in one Phil's a showman okay
yes so that could be a deficit because I
know Chris is gonna be very motivated no
one wants to lose to their dad in
anything but to Phil is crafty and I
feel like Phil is gonna know an arm
angle or something I could I could I
wouldn't put a bass fill a little leg
pinch yeah Chris right beforehand but I
think I'm gonna go with the old man
strength of Phil Wow Hey look I would
agree with you up until about six months
ago yes and Christopher was here over a
few days and he knows he'd whooped my
ass in a heartbeat but you push them
around well you know I got injuries
right okay I got some issues no I could
not armwrestling him but I
back to when I was in college you know
how stupid we are
yeah and I won my fraternity's arm
wrestling contest right and because I
and I'm interpreting a couple D lineman
yeah and it's not a football players
though they're not Texas football
players different arm wrestling category
there we were Casey Anthony Jean Rogers
I was hey I used to talk crap to the
defensive lineman I played against
sometimes so what are you gonna do I'll
whip your ass if you keep talking to me
like that so yeah I don't think I would
have done that the big 12 just like you
said but I agree dad you do to take like
I said I tell people all the time in the
Greenwich eats and Equinox he's right
now when dad and I go work out like we
worked out a year ago we're gonna do the
exercises he's best at we said this but
I don't really care he is 60 okay
he's plus 60 and yes it would be
embarrassing like I'd be like damn dad's
doing 105's first set to eight what
thump like I'd be have to talk to myself
back okay here we go let's just grab the
hundred so we don't get embarrassed it's
it's pretty unbelievable no we're taking
film I can only do so many exercise we
did it right now right now yes right now
I mean yes okay you know all day
I didn't go do anything at him I'm going
down all right let's go your pick Phil
like blows dust in your eyes should I
pick real football ridiculous football
personal legs and ass marijuana self
scouting animals or big Phil which one
should I pick god
that's ours categories today yeah okay
Phil you know marijuana okay legs and
ass all right here we go so legs and ass
this question is from at peckin v tion I
don't even know how you say that would
you rather have sake one barclays legs
and ass or LaRon Landry is arms and
traps sake one barclays legs and ass or
LaRon LaRon landries arms and traps
going legs and ass yeah I'm going like
yeah me too hey Laurent is gonna get a
lot of girls at the club yeah and look
real good in tight t-shirts and gonna be
awesome
but it's not like sake wands hurtin in
that department and legs and ass are
gonna get you a lot more money than than
Cheston oh my god I just want I'd like
to have that feeling just to take off
and run again oh my gosh that's great
you know I didn't realize how great it
was to be able to go and workout and
sprint and all those things and now it
can't do anything ever you go boy I wish
I could do it now but okay but there we
go let's do one more question from that
category here Logan H underscore eighty
you're about to get in a fight and you
have to choose one quarterback as your
backup who are you choosing oh my god
that's pretty easy you know right now
he's right now oh no cuz in our prime
may not take Jim Kelly cuz you know he
just wanted the action he wouldn't even
care if he got his ass beat listen the
Kelly brothers I used to see him I go oh
my god if you punch them right in the
face you will break your hand
rough nirupa oh my god are they rough
and tough oh man one quarterback in
today's game oh my gosh if you got into
a fight it's hard to not take number one
in Carolina yeah Oh Cam Newton's a
fighter though yeah is he a fighter
though yeah that's a big question you
know I mean I yeah he is imposing I
doubted carson wentz who's very imposing
to carson winters I mean Manny is raw to
like you like he's one of those guys if
he gets your hands on your butt's going
to the ground and then when you know
once it goes to the ground you gonna get
whooped
I think I got mine I know I'm I'm going
with Philip Rivers really know
kids no hell I can now I don't wrestle
him right now and take us down to the
heart there's no way you know Philip I
love fellow but I love its attitude feel
alright I got one let's know who you got
I'm going go who I'm going to Andrew
Luck Wow yeah yeah that's a good one too
oh I gotta go old school
now now I would just get beat up alright
what it's oh there's somebody to back me
up yes I'd like to all the first time to
say timeout this is gonna be my
substitute and I'd tag team Terry
Bradshaw Terry Bradshaw would fights the
money for sure oh my god the reason I
like Andrew Luck is Andrew Luck would be
like whatever you need I'm your best
friend and he's like I'm gonna give you
everything and since we all have to
throw anything you know we're throwing
punches we're not throwing footballs
yeah he can handle your yeah he's uh
he's a 260 pounds so he's probably 235
now but 225 of it is bone-in tendons and
stuff like that I mean it's we're
missing is a big structure who we listen
we're men I know we're missing one who
dak Prescott for he'd have to be in that
combo right he's thick and all that and
you need enough Andrew Luck is just ugly
enough to want to fight baby has a
pretty face
Philip Rivers has children to protect
Andrew Luck is out here just for the
love of the game alright let's do one
more question with Phil on the phone
Sims you're picking the category let's
do let's do let's do ridiculous for
violin that he's gotten one that was I
was hoping you'd pick that one John
McGahey @j a McGehee on Instagram what
is more awkward both instances Chris
Sims is stuck in an elevator with either
Tom Brady explaining why he didn't have
him as the number one quarterback on his
list or explaining to Blake bortles why
he talks so much [ __ ] and why he stinks
and is at number 70 on your list
all right let's asked us to fill first
fill wait was there more to that no that
was it so you're in an elevator
that isn't an elevator well you know
it's easy if he's in the elevator stuck
in there with Blake bortles and you know
by the way Blake bortles yeah he could
be up in that fight you're right let me
tell you what he's not he's a giant he
is and he'll you know he gets hit
blindsided and I think aw man and and
nothing doesn't it up and I know Phil
what did you think about the whole
bortles as a 70th quarterback thing as
that was going on well you know I did
it's funny I took me a while to catch on
so I think Christopher was having fun
with it and then of course Dan leba
tarred them hurt it I guess I only know
the origin of it how it came about but
it wasn't about hit quarterback was it
quarterback he now even really wins the
ball yeah it's throwing the ball more
than anything yes right now
so bortles is definitely more awkward
one I am would say so too I can be real
with Tom I don't think I'm gonna be
worried by that and we want to get in
the conversation with deflategate in the
in the and the elevator for Tom to I
could be rule just get it all out of the
way in the elevator could be real that I
think Tom could probably handle it - I
do the elevator he might be tricky right
you know I will tell you this about you
- today yeah this is a very creative
thinking about you and you know that
marijuana you sure y'all didn't smoke a
little marijuana but y'all need to get
something flowing those dumbass brains
well that doesn't mean we didn't do it
to prepare for this show but we didn't
we don't do it you know during the show
before the show they reminded Phil you
think I would allow that what's that you
think I would allow that to happen
before this podcast I don't think you
have any choice in that's great all
right Phil tnks down with me we're done
with you way to go boys that was great
clever stuff see Dad he like I love how
he he wants to rush us to call him every
time I'll talk for two hours really if
we just kept them there and we were like
you know you've been here for an hour he
would have been like oh is it been an
hour
I mean he always acts like he's got
something to do but he's he really got
nothing to do I love it let's go yes
category your choice animals animals I
would have loved to hear him talking
about pot break me down right because he
doesn't make fun of me every now and
then like if he calls me on a Friday
night or some hippy a call you already
been on the back patio huh all right so
this is one of two animal questions that
we had at Jack underscore billing seven
good morning I'm an avid listener of the
podcast and following on from the mascot
battles my dad and I got into a heated
battle into which animal would be best
suited for every position in the NFL I
think that would be an interesting
discussion and I'd like to know which
animal you could put where that would
take an entire podcast so I'm thinking
let's do a quarterback running back and
wide receiver here what animals you
wanted each position Oh Phil would pick
Terry Bradshaw and I don't think it
doesn't need to be like we don't have to
be like which animal could have called a
football like I'm thinking I put a
dolphin at quarterback right you got to
pick an animal that has some brain
traits like yeah you know what let's do
quarterback running back and D lineman D
lineman
D lime and I always think of rhinoceros
okay like just a mean angry rhinoceros
that's what I think especially the D
tackles the d-ends might be able but the
D tackles I do I just think of them as
me coming back I think of a warthog low
center of gravity
are they faster oh baby then they get a
little steam behind them yeah I was also
thinking you could just cheat and make
them a bird and just fly yeah you could
you know you could gonna be tough for
the rhinoceros then come back I don't do
quarterback is in essence saying what is
the most athletic animal that exists no
combined with smart oh no you can't say
because I'm not good the cheetah doesn't
get to be the quarterback or the leopard
sheet is the most athletic and something
I actually think the leopard should
probably be the running back right
there's a great strength size
combination shuddhi through the hole
they can catch a squirrel on a tree just
think about that 180 pound cat can jump
around a tree and get your squirrel it's
insane actually all about it right
sounds like a running back sounds like
it running back to me right and they can
also carry double their weight up into
the trees
sounds like say Kwan Barclays we're
talking about kale I'm just telling you
they're gonna have a cat running back
having a dolphin at quarterback probably
doesn't make sense well we're not this
is none of this makes sense
okay and then quarterback wait what are
some other smart animals we're missing
in the world that we could put there
wall a Falcon dogs like I was like the
Australian Shepherd yeah smart animal
any shark
I think the quarterback should be
poodles that's [ __ ] poodles really
smart kind of uppity well-groomed well
very well-groomed need to have the white
and white proving it raccoon raccoon
forever yeah absolutely
grassy nifty dirty dirty going through
the sewers rivers good tell Phillip
Rivers my dad said that I hope he books
crap out of my dad Chris you're picking
the next category okay I'm just trying
to think of things we haven't hit here
in a second well we've hit every
category
let's go personal personal all right let
me get the personal section up here all
right here we go let's see here which
one I've indeed which one - I want to go
into here alright so let's go with this
question from your buddy
that's personal all right Tom Gough here
at kill Gannon did any teams commit to
Simms before the draft and did any of
them break their promise I don't know if
we've ever talked about this I think so
either
yeah the Raiders yep
the Raiders Al Davis they had the last
two picks of the first round 31st and
32nd pick because they had maybe in
Washington traded for John Elway I mean
John Gurdon Tennyson the head coach so
yeah it was I'm gonna blank on his name
he was a defensive lineman from Colorado
Colorado right and then it might have
been I can't remember who the other one
is but waste whatever look a Thomas but
either way ow ow when I left there I'm
not gonna say he promised yeah but he he
made me feel that if I was on the B
basically said if you're on the board at
the end of the second
first round Nnamdi also banana Tyler
Tyler Braden right this was in person
you're talking about in person yes and
he goes if you're on the board he goes
at the end of the first you're you're in
our plans right now we're really
thinking about you and I walked away
and of course Marc Trestman was there at
the time Callahan was the head coach and
I walked away from all my visits going
ooh the Raiders like me the best and I
think there's a good chance the Raiders
take me maybe with one of those last two
picks of the first round now I've always
heard that I was still in their plans I
don't know what happened quarterback in
that dress no they did not
they still again and I'm sure they've
kind of felt like again and still had
years left which he really did he got
hurt the next year right with his neck
injury but that would be the one I
looked at and go they led me to believe
that they're gonna be more serious and
and I don't think they ever got serious
with it because I think I would have
heard from my agent the night before the
draft or anything like that we're even
again hey the Raiders there's still a
chance there I had a feeling the night
before the draft that I was going to
fall I knew that already my why why did
you have the thing because of my age and
it basically got back to me like teams
hadn't got back to him and they all went
dark and that's usually not a good sign
gotcha all right let's do let's do one
more question from this category while
we're here this one's for both of you
Matt Stalcup at penguin MOOC 808 if you
could play for any team today where
would you go ooh let's go your turn
this this soundboard is going to be
perfect I'm done yes okay we're gonna
eliminate the Eagles and pick your
second team that you would go to we did
this for the college teams on the last
mailbag but you didn't do it for the pro
teams so we're just picking the team
that we'd want to play on live in the
city yeah you want to live in the city
compete for Super Bowls whatever is
important to you I mean look LeBron went
to LA the rams made a ton of trades this
year there's a lot of excitement about
it
Chargers or the Rams I think to be in a
city like that would be a lot of fun I
don't have any interest in living in
Jacksonville but I think the Jaguars are
exciting but I would probably pick the
Chargers actually I like Anthony Lin I
like LA and then also like to where the
San Francisco 49ers and play for our
favorite coach in the NFL Kyle Shannon
that that's a spend it's a special
Jersey
I think of nostalgia first yep that's oh
yeah the 49ers are one of those teams
that certainly crossed my mind right up
the top I think the team that I would
look for there's so many things that
play into this but I think if you just
tell me the things that are important
okay living in the city tradition the
fan base all those things I think of the
Chicago Bears I'm not gonna do the
Giants of course I know they're very
they're special to me but the Chicago
Bears I feel I gave you could go to that
city and you could be the man at
quarterback and win a Super Ball oh my
gosh you're gonna be you're gonna go
into another stratosphere of that city
of the way they are sports man so Sims
of Chicago's on the clock you be yelling
oh man Sims next category let's go back
to pot we have to talk about pot and
let's go back to pot all right so this
question coming from at Pikeville on
Instagram good stop
Pikeville you kidding I'm not kidding
all right Jim we do without without
naming names
you have Sims tell us the story of the
first NFL player he ever smoked weed
with now naming names yes no dry
snitching and actually before you even
answer the question what did this happen
before you got to the NFL or was this
once you were in the league good
question yes no no the first time I had
a real smoke session on the NFL with
teammates and
stuff like that I would say really you
know I might have had like a few little
rookie like one or two guys there
whatever end of June but I feel like the
first time I sat down was after training
camp my rookie year like training camp
had broke now we're at home going
through your normal schedule but you're
still in the preseason and III can at
least name one guy I know he won't share
yeah Dwight Smith ain't gonna care he
was a part of that session he knows that
was my buddy right that was my best
friend of the team so yeah a lot of the
times I'm not gonna name the rest of the
people there but damn we were let's get
- Dwight's house after practice if we
knew we had time and nothing the next
day there was gonna be about four or
five other guys there he had a real huge
couch I run a huge TV some people were
gonna roll up and there was gonna be
more than one to two there was gonna be
two to three months going at the same
time in opposite directions in watching
games always always watching games and
if he weren't watching games we were
playing Madden against each other at
that point - but yes MBA everybody was
basically except we had money and then
we had Dwight Dwight saw me my man Zeke
was his name his name was dink but I
didn't understand what they were calling
him for a long time saying I was calling
him Zeke and they didn't tell me and
told my until we got back from Tokyo and
they go why do you call him Zeke and I
said because that's his name and they
said no his nickname is dink and I was
like damn I thought you've been calling
him Zee I would call him secretly on
like a southern accent so I still call
him Zeke
to this day he was what the role of Zeke
was not only the roller he was I mean
the man skilled in very many areas but
I'll tell you the thing he came in handy
and the smoke senses nope
his cooking his wings he made the best
fried chicken wings I put him against
any restaurant and neat in the whole
country that's in value the best wings
there are came from Zee so he was always
there and he was always cooking he was
my man he gonna think that a lot of
people have groups like that yes I mean
yes I do
yeah I mean as we know I mean without
getting too deep into this topic you
know guys got you know they come from
nothing they've been around
nothing their family in a lot of cases
is really their best friends right
because maybe they're all together so
they all go there they live together and
everybody's got the rover in the squad
first time you smoked first time are you
nervous where you're like guys like are
we sure like oh I was I was high school
ID really no I meant I'm in college I'm
an NFL oh I was tested right I knew I
was good so I was yeah I'm ready to go
you're the rookie smoking with the
veterans are you who I'm smoking yeah I
got to be invited it's certainly not and
then it's probably got to be cleared
like I'm not again I'm not gonna name
the other people are there but I'm sure
Dwight cleared it with all okay I'm
bringing the property white boy
quarterback over is everybody cool with
that the early 2000s box backwoods to
backwoods big off all right you're up
here seriously all right so let's go
ridiculous football again all right I'm
gonna go I've actually been looking
forward to asking this one so this is
from cam Nadeau on Instagram hey Adam
big fan of the show got a question hey
cam I got a question you and Simms might
like to argue on the podcast which NFL
player would make the best team if they
clone themselves and played at every
position for example a team of 53
Julio's versus a team of 53 Khalil max
that's a really interesting question
yeah so the first thing when I saw this
question the first thing I thought of is
you need someone who can play every
position exact can't put an offensive
lineman at running back because they'll
get tackled ten yards you know so yeah I
felt like it was 53 Gronk's was the
first thing I thought I was gonna go
tight-end
yeah cuz I could do like a little Oh
line D line can run and catch 53 Travis
Kelce Yeah right like that to me I'm
thinking of other ones you know I don't
know man good luck up against 53
Fletcher Cox's holy crap you're right I
don't know if you guys will be able to
throw or catch you're gonna be a ground
game pretty heavy ground game man so
good news we're gonna fill the box with
a lot of Gronk tsa's what about that was
gonna say Landon Collins I know it's got
to be those like in-between guys that
are got strength and bruton size but all
53 Todd girlies now
just the line play leo is interesting
Julio and Khalil Mac are both good ones
that's that's where my mind or go
offensive or defensive III do think
offense just cuz I think of throwing
like I when I think a cool Mac I'm like
I wish I could see him throw a ball one
rhyme because he may it might be a total
is what about 53 Cam Newton's Wow that
is that's an interesting one it is
because you see him out there I mean
there's only one quarter rack you could
even say like take on that D know what
actually might be the best one Patrick
Peterson we know that Patrick Peterson
can throw he wins a lot of those
throwing competitions against Carson
Palmer down here yes and he's a 4-3 guy
right Annie's got good hands and he punt
returns kick returns he's a very but on
the lines you're gonna be about to be
trouble right yeah I think I would go
with drunks 53 Grunk 63 Gronk and I hold
I hold a side of me that goes man if I
could just see Von Miller Khalil Mack
throw the football I might have picked
them I just don't know I've seen Grunk
throw it so we can do I know he can do
it to like at least complete to the wide
open ones yeah give us your pick raise
me Zach Ertz just let go I'm not gonna
do that what I'm gonna settle in I know
I'm thinking I'm gonna go 453 miles
jacks oh wow that's a good one that's a
lot of Bison Shack is big enough to
place any position could play safety
linebacker you could rush the passer and
runny blade some running back it's
either him or Shaq Thompson I'm going
miles don't miles that's a good one in a
game of 53 Gronk's versus 53 miles jacks
who do we think win oh man miles that's
got me thinking I'm guessing he can
throw too he can do and I'm saying yeah
hell yeah I won when Simms
pick a category let's go
we picked here in a little bit have we
taken animals we've done one animals and
one legs and ass and one real football
it's got to be one of those three all
right let's go animals let's go animals
all right this is this is a quick one
our last animals question here that
animals is off the board would you
rather fight one hundred duck-sized
horses are one horse-sized duck it's
Jared urns in hmm 100 quick answer here
one hundred duck-sized horses or one
horse-sized duck well I think I'd go
with the the first one one hundred
duck-sized horses
Manna Dey a horse that's a duck is
that's gonna scary right okay they might
first of all their beak and they're
flapping of the wing could be very deep
duck sized horses you just Momo I feel
like I could just throw haymakers just
twist in a circle and throw my fist out
I'm gonna win now yes you have to ask
yourself this do you want to die against
one duck that eats you or do you want to
go down with your arm in the air as you
are completely covered by little baby
watching defeat why are you meaning
defeat you just taken to feel like I'm
gonna lose both I just think whenever
this questions asked people
underestimate how much I'll 100 it's a
lot if there was 100 little horses
coming at you for me if it's one I have
to find one weakness the other way I
need to be kicking and punching
constantly to nurse they trample me I
don't have endurance I'm gonna I want it
to be like Coneheads where all I need is
one shot of a pebble into the the big
Ducks face
all right left go the next category do
you know that part in the movie and
cause but for a lot of our audience no
but I think Coneheads he goes up there
I'm from France I'm from France and he
has like the golf club because he
learned how to play golf right and
there's this big monster chasing him and
he hits the golf the rock and it hits
him right in his throat and six and then
he dies Oh legs nice legs and ass all
right here we go
legs and ass let's see alright laughs at
Paul underscore Kessler pull up the
teams here guys yeah ranked the top five
legs and ass of the starting
quarterbacks in the NFL keep up the
great work hashtag legs and ass
Kyle Shanahan is the best coach in the
NFL looking for top five quarterback
bodies here
all right so Russell Wilson is not to be
in order but let's just get them on the
page I'm writing shunderson dak Prescott
is Cam Newton up there I'm picking all
the athletes yeah hold on I checked out
for a second yeah you did yeah Shannon
actually just text me that's why what'd
he say he told me don't let left go come
around this week we don't need to see
him dammit
yep that's the legs and ass I've putting
down already Russell Wilson yes
Cam Newton and dak Prescott yeah Russell
and dak are definite I got a just think
about a second for cam cams legs and ass
although impressive are not as godly as
the rest of his body
yes okay he's got nice legs he doesn't
have a trick mahomes great ass he the
guy does have a great ass I'll say that
Carson Wentz oh no no we're missing
Wentz has got pretty impressive lower
body but I think your two right off the
bat are definite I'm we're staying with
starters too right I actually think that
drew Brees has a good legs Ness he
squats like 800 pounds I got I got a six
quarterbacks written down right now okay
mmm that's all I got I think those two
this is the most serious Allen has good
legs and ass rookies I know I was also
thinking of like Mitchell true Brisky
he's got a nice legs and ass to Jacoby
Burr said I'm like thinking about but I
don't know if he's like a starter yet or
for classifying that alright so right
now we have dak in Russell Wilson
okay dak Russell Wilson so of Jacoby cam
mahomes Carson Wentz Drew Brees - Allen
and Travis Jack Russel Wilson yes
cam is gonna have to go on air for sure
I think Dirk car Derek Carr has a nice
little legs and tush on him actually I
think he's got a really well put
together legs and tush if you want to
look it up okay oh yeah and then yeah I
know what you mean
right yeah it is there's something there
whence I feel like I want to go when so
is the number five guy so you got
Russell DAC cam whence and Derek Carr I
think so
I know car might surprise people the
cars got a little bit more there's a
little more thickness to that man than I
think people would realize that the
measurement person you want to rank
those five okay Russell is number one
one dak is - mmm cam Derek and Carson
and then I'm gonna go I think I'm gonna
go I feel like I'm gonna go this has
been riveting no you do let's go loves
his little soundboard over there I'm
gonna go Tam because I say so
when's car cam went scarce and Russell
dak cam went sand car very happy far so
Josh I need you to get pictures of each
of their I honestly think Sims focused
harder on that then maybe your mock
draft this year I mean you just went I
feel like I had to really think about
this one the mock draft I mean I was
prepared for it yeah and you've put a
flag in the ground that this is this is
the thing that you are known for right
pick the next category okay next one
where you're gonna go to real football
game real football in football real
junior cab 17 in regards to the Second
Amendment of the podcast Constitution
Aaron Rodgers or guys that was
embarrassing
will Kyle Shanahan ever hire an
offensive coordinator I understand and
trust Daly's comments that Shanahan is a
next level of genius but even geniuses
need help look at belcheck he had a
defensive coordinator most of his tenor
as coach of the Patriots I just wonder
if an extra set of eyes on the offense
could propel the Niners past the
division and help them make the playoffs
I think that's definitely not the issue
right now I think that the the thing I
would look at is more than anything no I
don't think he's gonna ever give anybody
the title of offensive coordinator
that's that's definitely not going to
happen now to what
starting to happen in the NFL right and
you notice this on the Rams they don't
have the offensive coordinator right
they have a Aaron Cromer as the running
game specialist right and Shayne Waldron
is the past game special you go so
that's what I could see start happening
more and more I think it's happening as
it's already happening so you're right I
think it is somebody its first
especially when you have the offensive
coordinator head coach that's it's gonna
be but even like a Josh McDaniels in New
England he has no quarterback coach
because he's the offensive coordinator
and he goes you know what I don't want
anyway I'm gonna relay my message to the
quarterbacks directly so I'm gonna be
both I don't think anybody's gonna get
that title I think that's part of why
owners are also hiring the McVeigh's or
Shanahan's because they look at it and
go I'm paying you for this these are 30
points right and you can save me some
money by not giving somebody else that
title I think that's part of the selling
point to go that's one less thing on the
books so again I think mcveigh shiney
and those guys will never have that Oh
CJ
but don't get it messed up that they're
not going to be open to ideas and listen
from other people like yeah they're what
they say might be the final rule but at
the end like all week there are two guys
that are willing to listen to other
ideas and what people do I mean Kyle was
the offensive coordinator what McVeigh's
well Matt Lafleur was the OC for the
Rams last year yes he was so I bet you
like McVeigh basically did him a solid
last year and said I'll make you the OC
to help you on this year just run game
pass game right like we saw this with
the Eagles you get like three great
coaches DeFilippo Frank Reich Doug
Peterson you can really create magic yes
but I don't think that's the issue at
the 49ers going forward I think it's
defense defense defense and Kyle is
gonna scheme you in a way to get some
points to make a competitor up out of
legs and ass we're out of animals
questions all right I would like pot you
would like pot alright so this is gonna
be our last our last pot question okay
Chris you touched on this a little bit
better hurry up Liam Oh in 30 how does
big Phil feel about the devil's lettuce
and his sons prolonged use of the
Blessed
grass my dad Phil Simms my dad he
doesn't love it the fact that I do it I
mean yeah he does not he's he's come to
this point of his life where it's just
he understand this is me and that's what
I do and he doesn't judge me I think
that's you know a lot like the older
generation I don't think they you know
quite understood it until I got around
them a little bit I you know and the
type of person that does do it in front
of it I'm not I wasn't like when I had
time off and what about you and your
playing well I was playing like I told I
was in the drug program for six out of
the eight years so you were not doing so
I wasn't doing it very often right was
that something that your dad was on you
about yeah well yeah he definitely was
my age did you yeah you knew my issue he
knew I had usually told him I don't know
if he knew I was suspended on the
program for six out of the eight years
but I also anybody would tell you like
and as do you guys know I'm a very
honest person as far as I just I wear it
on my sleeve but if you want to know
what I think about something I'm gonna
tell you you probably are gonna hear
about it before you even ask me anyways
because I say so that's damn right so at
some point I'm gonna say around 30 or 31
when I would come home in the summer or
have time off or whatever like I was
like man I'm sick of like hiding in the
woods to smoke a joint and I was like no
[ __ ] you you want me here at the house
I'm gonna be on the back patio you guys
can drink that's killing more people
than anything but I can't sit here and
hit the weed you know three or four
times so that's how I first kind of
broke him down right he doesn't love it
of course because he's a father and it's
not the healthiest thing in the world
but I think he he understands it's what
I like to do to cut loose and I know
he's worried about he's worried that as
Chris gets older he's going to become
hey man thanks to me man so you up
alright so Sims you're up so remaining
categories here real football ridiculous
football personal self scouting and
that's it no more big fill out it all
right let's go personal it was that last
call - yes it was all right
let's go personal here um let's see
which one do I want to go with all right
I'm done it's really hard with your
salary button all right here we go this
is a good one cuz you'll this is this is
gonna be fun all right at Ben's 296 Sims
if you had to compare left go as a
bleacher report employee and podcast
host to a current NFL player who would
it be
Oh golly a lot of pull up the team's
this episode a lot of pull up the teams
so he's comparing me to who and in an
NFL player as a bleacher report employee
who is his pro player comparison so let
go as an employee very creative guy yes
crushes it on the podcast every week
little disorganized needs help with his
calendar at times so you know you can't
always trust him to show up on time but
creative lots of great ideas and when he
does show up you know he's gonna kick
ass bring in the a game so who is that
guy that's a little deep undetailed like
that you know can be a bit of a diva
right and I thought of receiver like
I've thought of like you know obj that
type of guy he's not quite that good so
I'm not gonna give him obj I'm just
sitting waiting I've never thought about
this so I'm just trying to think of
those strengths right there do you got
one no I don't have one actually I ask
the questions okay do you have someone
in your mind yeah but I'm gonna wait for
Sims
[Music]
what's coming hold on oh my gosh we can
weave me at it here he's um I know I
don't I'm thinking I've receivers are
the ones that all seem to come to my
head he's not a linebacker or anybody on
the defensive side of the ball right
he's not a D lineman no he's not a no
lineman no he's like he's a running back
he's David Johnson the correct answer is
Big Bend slightly out of shape kind of a
control freak a lot of a diva doesn't
really work that hard to practice but
shows up for the guy I think you're less
of a diva in a nicer person than big bed
[Music]
I flattened all your tires and I like
the data Johnson one I gave your son a
wedgie but I feel like it isn't see me
what Dave Johnson's a very nice calm yes
oh yes he sits it's like he's he's about
to hit the scene in a big way like the
people in the business know he's
big-time okay but the rest of the
mainstream world hasn't caught on yet
I'm Kevin Coleman like that but also
there's that receiver element but that's
the problem where I cried though his
body makeup because I so hard for me
receiver who that could be
that's your actual football playing pro
player comparison
yes exactly all right who's up here left
go I am ridiculous football okay here we
go
what was that last one that personal
that was personal yeah that was personal
all right so at Hunter Westfall here
with the new Jurassic Park movies
creating hybrid dinosaurs I want y'all
to create a perfect hybrid quarterback
of the guys currently in the NFL so he
said size speed arm strength so let's go
with those three categories and let's go
with a head as well so size speed arm
strength and whose brain do you want
let's go with brain first so when I
think of brain I'm thinking Brady I'm
thinking breeze those are my two head
guys I think I got a girl's brain I
gotta go Brady - I've reached the point
with Brady where his ability to just
pick a part of defense and come out
there and you
completely shift everything and grab
everything they're just the way he's
approached his you know Bruin he was the
dumb one compared to Peyton and it's
amazing you know what's so funny is I
mean I've actually was thinking about
this today I mean just
first of all Tom yeah I mean Tom the
brain for thinking ahead of off the
field like oh I'm gonna start doing this
training in this setting and all of
those things that have gone into it
let it walk eaten was still wearing his
helmet in the jacuzzi we were trying to
get you know I'm want to get done so I
can drink beers remember even saying
another yeah while you were drinking
beers and you're losing miles per hour
and your fastball tom was at home
drinking spinach shakes and still 250
Bowery this is in tinkering with his arm
motion which is where I always think
about Payton dropped off because that
goes into the brain to of what you're
saying with Brady Brady was smart enough
to realize my throwing motions a little
off I'm not maximizing let me retool and
rehearse Brady is so healthy that if you
offered him tomatoes he'd say no thanks
you're so healthy that vegetables are
cheating right that's crazy
so Brady's brain strength we're gonna
shout our Patrick mahomes or Aaron
Rodgers I'm gonna go with Aaron Rodgers
still I can't give those guys that
little is that arm strength or is that
arm power I'm just good if we're going
arm anything it's Aaron Rodgers I don't
give a [ __ ] if it's not touch throw a
deep throw a virus a quickness and the
release all that is Aaron Rodgers
accuracy accuracy that's where hmm I
mean you know I tend to want to go Aaron
Rodgers there again but I think if we're
gonna just spread the wealth yes that's
where we go Drew Brees I think jube
Reese Drew Brees is so great at putting
in the ball in the right spot for his
receiver writing the slant back shoulder
kind of invented the back shoulder a
little bit you did I mean speed next and
then speed Lamar Jackson by the way a
lot of people deemed me and said at
Louisville do you have this somewhere
else oh yeah that he ran ahead
three three yeah and that was his like
sophomore year something like that
that's cool that's good to know though
yeah he ran I think a little bit slower
than J year Alexander who round like a
four three one so the four three three
and I'm not gonna say it wasn't laser
because it definitely wasn't laser but
also you
could say I don't know like Shakima
Alexander Hakeem Griffin you know he
might run a little faster because he's
so jacked up so I think Lamar would
around a four to five I mean well that's
usually what they say though like in all
seriousness but then also the laser
well yes but usually they that's like
something that is planned for in the
combine preparation is that you're gonna
Drennen lynn and all those things that
aren't really like hitting on all
cylinders for the workout on a random
wednesday how much does that give you
well III know like our guy always
thought it would be like maybe like a
tenth something out a tenth a hundred
sorry it's probably saying that goes no
I think he really did a hundred two
hundred like if you ran a 478 on the day
you could run for seven six I know I was
hopped up like man I've never been that
nervous I'm gonna find video like I told
you I was running down the track and I
promise you as my arms were pumping I
was going I'm running to 40 at the
combine I'm running to 40 at the combine
I'm running the 40 to combine what did I
run and then we got to think a leg so
he's going a little bit even though we
haven't seen him play so Wilson are you
asking me the rest of us and Lamar
doesn't get a body part cuz he hasn't
done anything yet okay sighs sighs was
the last one oh and that goes camp right
right so I would put Russell's leg Cam
Newton wins that one because every
person we've ever had it says when he
walks in the field you go holy crap I've
never seen the human being built like
this so that is your hybrid quarterback
here Thank You hunter Westfall Brady's
brain cam sighs Russell speed Russell's
legs
Rogers arm breezes accuracy right I like
that I like that I will say I will add
in Stafford's arm angle like the ability
to throw it from all the arm and I'm
getting deep in the window I've just got
a bleeped report alert and I'm gonna
tell you man it is big offseason Lakers
know it's more football Patrick Peterson
says about Josh Rosen quote Josh blew my
mind
my first week with him he's the future
of our franchise
or that t-shirt today my t-shirt all
right who's up here who's picking the
next question mind which one happen we
picked enough of self scouting I guess
self scouting all right let's go to self
scouting here all right this one is from
at Richie Sully
I applaud Simms for being forthcoming
but Adam how do you never give him [ __ ]
for this one episode excited one episode
chris says NFL teams labeled me a party
boy because they saw me on 6th Street
one time then two episodes later he
talks about failing the drug test it
reminds me of Chappelle's Rick James
skit when he says why should I step on a
man's couch I got more sense than to do
that [ __ ] helmet I stepped on his couch
loved the show cocaine's a hell of a
draw so you say the team's labeled you
as a party boy because you were at one
time but then you admit to being on the
drug program six out of your eight years
hey you're right there's hard that's
hard to defend because I guess what I'm
saying as far as like labeling as a
party boy in college you know again I'm
not that I'm not I was never trying to
say I was squeaky-clean like I drank I
smoked pot in college all that I was a
college student but I was not revolving
my life around partying anyone in your
draft class that was truly a party boy
we're about to dry snitch on somebody
I'm just trying to think of my draft
class like what is in your mind a party
guy a party guy that's like I'll pull up
your dress is that the partying is the
only thing that matters to him it's oh
it's every you know it's it's five
nights a week he finds some way to get
out get out and do something get his
buzz on whatever it may be
we're yeah listen I like to have fun but
I was like that you couldn't get me to
go out really that's what I'm saying so
the trio I was in perfect now the drug
program thing the trope program you
failed one time and yeah well I failed
one time got in for two years right
right and then I lost my spleen and I
thought I was clean and I had smoke but
just I didn't know that the spleen was
so pleased without the spleen is the
filter for your bottom then I got me
again
then I got in trouble with my non-guilty
DUI then down in Houston I think that
well I got cleared but I had to be I
never failed an NFL drug test that time
around but I had to stay in the drug
program just because I was arrested that
night for like six months so you were
extenuating circumstances there's the
2003 NFL Draft yeah dry snitch oh I'm
not dry snitching on anyone but I mean I
mean I don't think like there was
certainly I remember rumors of Charles
Rogers who ended up being somewhat of a
bust right yeah for the Lions Seaver
from Michigan State but other than that
I don't see anybody I'm just going over
the rest of these Bowl or a party game
no Kyle was a good dude um nice cute
would not be down for this no he doesn't
like this but it was you know 15 years
ago Charles Rogers I and just I don't
even know if it was partying how about
this could you see your now vet yeah
could you see the rookies that came in
yes
what were the telltale signs you can
always just tell the rookies who were
like you're like damn and don't know if
he's got it because every night is we
saw this girl and she had two cheeks
there were asses and then the next night
they come in they like it's the whole
story dude
there was two girls there last thing you
should have seen it funny thing about
they're all over so I know a lot of you
listen to us are in their 20s and early
30s and they party and it's really fun
it's great you know when you're not
partying and people tell you party
stories it's the same story let's I all
man song yeah it's funny it is funny
when you live in that life is the best
but you also start to get a feel to
because it's almost an NFL player it's
an NFL player but it's also that guy
who's like the we're supposed to be on
the field for a nine o'clock run workout
in May and it's always that guy who runs
in the locker room at 8:57 fully dressed
maybe from what he was wearing last
night still always yes that happens
definitely wearing there going out
clothes
definitely
or they can usually get the workouts
done you guys I know they've like
literally woke up at 8:45 and they've
timed out the drive takes 10 minutes and
I'm gonna show up and I can get dressed
in 37 seconds and get out there and
they're out there and you could tell
like oh damn I could smell the alcohol
you ever practiced hungover not only in
that high school story I think I told
you about yeah the only whatever the
only whatever I mean the NFL you were
never hungover for practice ever I would
never do anything like that I've never I
approached it too seriously and like I
said even with you know my marijuana
smoking like I told you I'm scheduled
regimented where I like they do never
gonna affect I am never least I do it
when he has to work I would I have to do
something I just don't like I don't feel
as good at doing my job like Friday 602
yes time exactly right yeah he's good
job good job still scouting they're also
from Ritchie Sully he said I just got my
whoa big offseason t-shirt in the mail
I'm when I won - nice shirt I'm heading
to Austin in July any bars with some
good Sims memorabilia in it lifelong
Giants fan will fly from Hawaii for an
invite to big [ __ ] I don't know
there's so much has changed since I've
been there like that red fence they
don't have your goodbye side street was
the place we used to go to all these
other stores they've turned over so much
sixth Street fifth Street if you're at
the airport go to Salt Lake up Salt Lake
okay
you got to do a little like syrup so I
got there late and it was closed like
Lake Travis like Austin something like
that get out on the lakes that's always
cool yeah the true thing is I think that
if you're in Austin having just gone
there again and I if you're young and
you want to do the bar scene that Street
is really really cool yeah there are so
many cool places in Austin yeah there's
like these little watering holes that
like you don't even know unless you're a
local and you can just like sit out
there and drink and also like get on the
lake go to the lake get in the cove sit
up with your boys get on the boat just
dock up next to another boat and just
this party boy over to school there yeah
wouldn't raft you left guy I'd have a
lot of concerns about you right now
yeah so I was day drinking
and I was wearing a Reggie Bush Saints
fake authentic Jersey when I was this
out college in college then I gotten
from this Chinese distributor
I was selling jerseys at Syracuse to
people and if you I could get like
authentic jerseys but the problem is
sometimes the numbers would come in too
close together so all the ones that
didn't look at I would just wear and I
had been daydreaming and it was in
Syracuse it's not Austin Austin every
day is a party day no big deal Syracuse
blizzard spring hits you would have
thought that we had been in Alaska for
40 days no one's going to class we're
all on the front porch and I have been
dating and I'm feeling good and I get a
phone call hey Adam how are you this is
NFL Films we thought we'd do our phone
interview right now you have any time
and I'm like hey oh yeah and they're
like all right they're asking me all
these questions and they go and they're
asking other questions and they get to
one point where they like listen we do
have a concern we do see on your resume
that you really don't have any football
experience and you know there will be
some watching a film you want to know
that we want to know what you're talking
about and again I'm a little and I go
listen if you want to talk about the
difference between a 4 3 and a 3 for
about the zone coverages of a cover 2 or
a cover 3 and I'm literally like holding
my mat and joystick and just like going
through the defensive like oh we could
talk about blitzes ohm blitzes or even a
middle linebacker double a gap blitz I
said we do all that and she goes oh you
clearly know what you're talking about I
got the internship that's a key to being
a party boy sometimes got to be able to
talk to my advocate on your feet yeah
all right I was like by the way I know
that you guys are in Mount Laurel New
Jersey any chance that new NFL Network
open up you could send me to California
they're like we do have a spot oh my god
all right Los Angeles I'm on the porch
oh my god
yeah good time that's amazing what
category you totally chickened out and
like you know what can I talk about
because you would have been hiccuping
and burping in personal personal okay
personal and then we got some good
football questions here all right
personal questions left comm sorry but
most of the personal questions for her
directed towards that your counterpart
right then I'll just try and keep up
couple a good story okay aalverson
aalverson Ethan had the hell did Chris
Sims meet his wife oh I met her in high
school at a friend's house in high
school yes I knew I knew there was this
new girl coming back into town that I
had not known about but if people were
talking about her and she was going to
marry she's all she was going to a
friend of mine a girl friend of Mines
house that in one night I was trying to
grind I met her there the high school
party high school friend's house went
from there I pursued her hard
recklessly relentlessly that's right and
she kind of fought me off for a little
while until she couldn't resist anymore
she went to school she was here in New
York I was at Texas we were on and off
my first three years a few years in the
NFL we were on and off I put her through
hell she stayed with me and that's
that's the special history yes Craig
carton over here alright serious
football we're running out of questions
questions here okay
ji a Meeks for Monday's mailbag episode
I'm a huge Packers fan and share your
guys man-crush with Aaron Rodgers but do
you think there's any area that he can
improve on from a skills or
psychological perspective anything with
Aaron Rodgers that he could improve on
or is he truly the most perfect no
there's one thing I'll say like mm there
I mean relatability yeah I mean there's
definitely been the leader
ship things yeah there doesn't sound
like it's always perfect I don't think I
don't I don't think that Greg Jennings
is the model guy and I I think that I
think there's like for him he played
with Brett Favre
and I think it's hard to go for Brett
Favre to anybody but there are a lot of
guys that that comment on Aaron Rodgers
personality and stuff like that any too
sensitive things like that and maybe
he's just an interesting guy I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say he's perfect
nobody's perfect now but that seems to
be I don't know an issue that some
people have with him I think so too and
I'll say this this is just from the
playing is playing perspect because I my
first thought went to what you said the
playing aspect of but we were gonna get
really nitpicky again this is the guy
that I think's the best quarterback that
ever played the sport but he's been so
jaded with people not being open and not
have being able to throw the football on
time that there are points here and
there where you go oh man if he just
took the five step and threw it to that
guy he was open right there right but
he's had so many other instances where
he does that in the guy's not there that
he goes well damn I'll just kind of
manipulate the defense with my eyes and
just wait a little bit longer until I
feel a little bit more comfortable with
the next guy I see open it's not that
different than his personality what's
going on in his personal life right I
feel like Aaron has been at a point
where he's he doesn't trust a lot of
people this is from the outside looking
in and all that stuff I've honestly
never even met the guy except I'm at
that wedding we're at Randall Cobbs
wedding I saw him at like a breed I
didn't think so I mean did you say hi
don't me just I didn't member yeah yeah
I was scared but I look at Aaron and I
think oh I'm gonna be a top pick I don't
go until 24 and it's on national TV
everything that's going on with this
family
wide receivers have come out and said
things afterwards I think Aaron is at a
point where I think jaded is really the
word where I think that a lot of people
have let him down and I don't think he
knows who to trust and eventually that
callus builds up and that when you can
trust people you don't and I think
that's sort of the the side of Aaron
that it's the chip on his shoulder
that has maybe gotten a little bit too
big and that's like this would happen a
lot of times where he would not have an
open receiver and Sims would go it's
because the last 20 times that run that
route he hasn't gotten open on the slang
right so it's hard it's hard that way I
don't know if Aaron's that impatient you
know at all it's hard it's it's it's
he's we're just saying that'll be the
one fall I would recognize he's pretty
damn close to perfect it's it's hard to
play the position the way he's been
asked to play I got another football
question to ask you guys here from Sean
O'Shay at Sean likes bacon we've seen
teams fall off a cliff when they're
rookie deal quarterback gets the big
money second contract Seattle Colts and
Ravens for example what can teams like
the Rams and the Eagles do to safeguard
themselves from that drop-off of the
quarterback of the of just the team
dropping off after the quarterback gets
their big money conscious go build
through the draft still have to continue
to attack to the draft to get in young
talent and have to be willing to cut the
cord yeah right you have to be Bill
Belichick lawyer Milloy
so two things here one talking about kam
chancellor made me realized how many of
those guys they got off the scrap heap
yeah like you get sure Earl Thomas 14th
pick overall whatever he was in the
teens kam chancellor 5th Richard Sherman
5th yeah Michael Bennett off the
scrapheap of Tampa Bay right you know a
Bobby Wagner I don't I think it was like
a second-round pick they really were
able to build all and that and then they
just haven't hit in the last few years
and then what was the second thing uses
the second thing is coming for when to
cut the court I read an article about
the guy that created spot track the
contract was a contract website Buffalo
guy yeah and he's just some guy that was
a side hustle and they were talking
about the way contracts are and the NFL
and he goes the Patriots are perfect he
said when you look at the build-up of
their contracts they're all paying guys
at every position in the top 15 but
they're not paying anybody in the top
five he goes so you pay everybody really
well but you don't pay anyone over the
top right I look at the Sixers to go
cross sport they got joelle embiid for
25 million dollars a year right now
looks like a bargain yeah you have to
sign the guy's a little early like you
got to get a little Russell Wilson 20
million does it grow
wherever that's why we're complaining
about crunk right now you need to either
pay a guy early and try and lock them in
and trust your analysis or you kind of
got a fine you gotta go man Jamie
Collins is gonna ask her too much and I
don't want to pay him that kind of money
we gotta move on and trade them or never
and it's it's but the value you get back
needs to be good - is there anything -
Walsh Bill Belichick they all refused to
pay those guys when it went didn't add
up
is there anything - getting out ahead of
it with your quarterback and doing it
like the Patriots do with Brady where
they pay him a little less but he's
incentivized like should could the Rams
in the Eagles be convincing Carson Wentz
or Jared Goff laying the groundwork for
that right now
yes they can be I mean you just you soak
quarterbacks like that you really I'm
and again I think I would be a quarter
belly that's like where I wouldn't be
worried about being the highest-paid guy
I don't know so no there's something to
that as far as I think let's goes got to
write you get out in front of certain
contracts that's a quarterback is a
tough one it's tough all together you
hope through a McVeigh or Doug Peterson
that they can continue to convey through
their quarterback meetings how great it
is we have the team and we have this
spending to hope doing that whence when
it comes time he'll realize like oh damn
I can't take away from all these other
things we had I'll try to be somewhat
realistic with what I ask
yeah you try and lock him up early and
then I guess the offer for quarterbacks
you just there's always these rushes
where everyone out does each other but
other positions you just got to be smart
you know but it's tough like that for
the for the Rams and the Eagles they
share one thing in common they have a
defensive lineman that's gonna worn a
lot of money over the next few years -
they have a quarterback on their defense
Aaron Donald and Fletcher Cox Aaron
Donald's gonna make this really
interesting
Fletcher Cox number was big yeah wasn't
insane no but Aaron Donald's gonna want
an insane summary and he's gonna deserve
it yeah but at the same time they're
gonna have all that money in Harran
Donald Todd Gurley and Jared Goff you
know all that Brandon cooks contract he
ain't getting a big deal that's why they
went for Brandon cooks never see me
walking sure Marcus Peters I don't know
what's gonna happen in a few years of
that Merck you know a lot of money there
right I keep to leave he's gonna be gone
yeah in Dhamma can sue he is gonna be
gone that Rams team is built to win the
Super Bowl in the next two to three
years and if they don't the Rams
evaporate quick I think the biggest
thing in this conversation is like what
we saw with Seattle Seahawks you know
and you're running an organization your
loyalty has to be to the emblem and the
organization it cats to the question for
the Seahawks that's hard if you were
gonna not pay somebody right who would
who should they not I think oh yeah it
was Bennet Chancellor Thomas Wagner who
do you not pay yeah I know I know that
would have been telling and they just
missed on every offensive lime in the
trip based on offensive lineman
certainly that you know I don't know if
they had to give all the money they gave
to all those guys but they've listened
they were in a tough situation there's
no doubt about that but my big thing is
I think not about what they paid them is
just that they held on to everybody a
year or two too long that's where I look
at it all right two more questions then
we're done here
one more football question at the
infinite pet what quarterback wide
receiver quarterback wide receiver combo
from a past era do you think would have
the most success in today's NFL mm-hmm a
quarterback wide receiver duo bypass era
I was thinking like a Steve Young Jerry
Rice type of thing it's awesome cuz it
was more mobile yeah I mean Steve would
be probably more dangerous this day and
age the NFL than he would have been back
then so that's a good one
and I jump in your mind well I feel like
we've said this guy's name like seven
times because my father father yeah but
like Swann and Bradshaw I think that
would have been pretty special Swann was
a could do everything type of receiver
he could have been that guy that's a
deep thread back shoulder guy what about
Aikman and Ervin yeah I don't know if
it's like to me it's not far enough out
of the loop to go let's be
groundbreaking this day and age I feel
really have that kind of combo I'm
trying to think of the Unitas and
Raymond there I mean Raymond berry or
that damn tight end they have that's the
one that's like that was legit
Mackey yeah John Mack John Mackey with
Unitas what was the original question
their quarterback was a barcliff brand
that's the one I mean clip branches was
like the Tyree kill really Oh football
at that point he is one where I look at
and just go that could have been a
special more than 500 passes for just
under 9,000 yards and sixty seven
touchdowns seventeen point three yards
per carry
that's insane so that would be what I
would look at right there whether it's
Stabler and Branch Plunkett and branch
Rachel and Swan Bradshaw and Swan you
know hey stall back and Drew Pearson
would be pretty damn good to her yeah
all right all right
Marvin Sterling Sharpe oh man that's one
that I never really got to appreciate
Starla yeah and nobody did
he was just becoming the best receiver
in football when it happened it's thinks
more of a babe Parrilla Geno cappelletti
guy surprisingly you said Phil Simms and
Donkey was that receivers named Lionel
Manuel you said there was two questions
left I know I have one more right here
oh so it's that receiver saying see
that's the problem about filler I was
joking
Phil Simms all right so the last
question here this is a question for you
too but we're also going to put this out
to the listeners and the commentary
timbers and hot dogs all right so rod
Simba our senior music producer for
vodka what do we this is a question for
the commenters listeners what do we call
ourselves as a collective fanbase
I suggest potheads any of you guys have
anything else so in the comments section
we had two other suggestions East
Elliott mate said mother hens little
chicks and ever the incredible milk 14
said Sims and the left hos pot heads is
pretty good I don't know if we're gonna
beat that I don't know if you guys have
any thoughts off the top of your heads
but we want to just kind of use this as
a launching gas put it out there Robson
but I do like pot heads that's a good
one to start with let's pot heads is the
leader in the clubhouse right now I
refuse to be anything under the realm of
you mother hands little chicks like that
one I'm gonna get that on a t-shirt and
walk around with that
yeah mother hen okay that's all I got
left all right all right so I do like
the pod heads and then what was the
other one the limbs oh that's that's not
good that's not proper for these times
all right that felt good I love the fan
question you guys asked questions and us
also self Scout us to the point that I
really really appear honestly I don't
know about you guys I didn't have to
answer any self scouting questions I
enjoy the self scouting because I like
to know that people are paying attention
and calling us on self Scouting about me
than the party boy and all that was a
great question yeah there any other self
scouting that we didn't get to know that
was it I would say there's morning no
there was that was it the thing that I
appreciate about self scouting and I
kind of want to end it here is I I think
that what we're trying to do with Simms
in love Co is very simple I don't think
there is there are people that are
talking about the NFL that are either
gonna be completely truthful to you or
will admit that they don't know
everything I know that Simms watches
more film than anybody why because it's
physically impossible to watch more film
than Simms cuz he watches every game I
also think that every time that I
watched people talk about football they
act like they know everything and I love
admitting that we don't know everything
right and I also think that I look
around the landscape everyone on the NFL
Network every show is not gonna be 100%
honest because they can't they're not
going to talk about Jameis Winston the
way they should they're not going to
talk about marijuana and CBD in the NFL
they're not gonna be honest about all
these players because they're afraid
what's gonna happen and I think we're in
a cool spot and I think that the thing
that makes me know that it's cool is
when we get DMS or messages or posts
into US and then us three me Josh tim's
alt text each other and go holy crap
like when in Bop a had a run and we were
getting messages that were the same
messages that we're texting each other
we're building a community and I'm super
excited about it and it's a lot of fun
and we appreciate you guys so much
because that's what makes it special
thank you guys hear the music federic
thank you for rounding up all the
attachments and do all that work let it
go Fendi for Sims peace out homies for
federic good evening everybody and for
the lef koe man we appreciate y'all
Simpson left go if you give a [ __ ] about
the NFL then you need to be listening to
us we are the players podcast and
sometimes we curse too much have a great
weekend hit us up in the DMS at Sims and
Lefko Josh or I will respond Sims
doesn't understand what DMS are we
should get Sims on the DM is one day we
just let him go while just do like I
read it
ask me anything could do that I could do
that good alright guys peace out enjoy
your weekend be well talk to you soon